hey you guys
it's the movie retrospective
and uh this movie i believe we are
popping h uh tom's hg lewis cherry on
this one is this the first herschel
gordon lewis movie that you have seen
yeah i've never seen one this is the
southern masterpiece
that's southern master i thought you
would like this one i actually i've seen
all of his well i haven't seen all of
his movies because he made a [ __ ] ton
but uh i've seen all of his quote
unquote blood trilogy uh which first
started with blood feast and then this
one 2000 maniacs and then color me blood
red i actually reviewed color me blood
red on my flickers of fear show but i
wanted to save 2 000 maniacs because i
thought you would uh enjoy it very much
yeah this is this one looks it was
filmed here in florida yeah there's some
giveaways there's florida you know them
stuck with stuccoed interiors but it's
supposed to be taking place probably in
place like mississippi
i've i you know what i'm not really
entirely sure because there is a sign
that says augusta georgia like 111 miles
or something i've seen some reviews that
said it was maybe supposed to be south
carolina okay but i don't think they say
and i mean like the vacationers that
turn up in it say they're going to
florida
for vacation
so
i don't really know i'm just i you know
i i thought it could be anything but
it's it's not because it's florida
because it was shot in st class this
movie the theme of this movie is
southerners
trolling yankees and
they're trolling the yankees in this one
well significantly more than trolling
they're actually like torturing and
murdering them well that's in the movie
that's the characters in the movie i'm
talking about the people who are making
this movie looking are trolling all
right and they're they're also trolling
southerners too they're doing [ __ ]
over-the-top
impersonations of over-the-top southern
accents and they're doing cheesy
yankee accents and stuff and what's
funny is like
everybody in this movie is a southerner
pretty much i could tell it seemed like
everybody's out there
but the ones playing southern rolls
their accents are not authentic they're
[ __ ] going way over the top almost
amos and andy well yes you know let's
see like like that and then the
southerners that are trying to sound
like yankees just sound like more more
close to just regular southern accent so
you can see the difference between the
two it's just [ __ ] funny yeah i guess
they had to go
they had to go like way over the top
yeah it's over the top and um
it's kind of like uh troll about
trolling yankees and southern revenge
porn but it's funny
interestingly you know what's crazy
about this um you know the thing about
h.g lewis is that
he's um he's actually not a southerner
by birth he's from pittsburgh
um and he then he moved to chicago later
on although he did teach literature at
the university of mississippi for quite
a long time okay however his longtime
collaborator who i think his name was
dave friedman um who was a producer and
like a sound guy in most of his films
and stuff was from birmingham alabama
but then moved to chicago later on and
actually h.g lewis did retire to florida
in his uh later life he actually only
passed away a few years ago he died in
2016. okay he lived for quite a long
time because he was uh you know he was
from the 20s but it's a great movie it's
way ahead of its time it's almost kind
of like along the lines of devil's
rejects or you know
like a slasher flick it's kind of like
something you'd see coming out of italy
but more coherent better and it's 1964.
yeah 1964.
and me and jenny are marveling over the
uh the southern girls makeup and chat
they it was 60s fashion and we were just
looking at how goth they looked
if you actually just dyed their hair
black they would look like goth with
their makeup and [ __ ] just kind of good
fashion the dudes in this are just kind
of just over the top redneck caricatures
uh but it's all kind of like fun and
games if you ask me uh it was
juxtapositions between
horrible [ __ ] happening to to kind of
like innocent people and they're people
laughing about it when it's going on
it's kind of a weird distorted mixture
of [ __ ]
reality and spoof it's just
it's kind of like
a thousand house of a thousand corpses
or devil's rejects kind of well you can
like rob zombie was is really into h.g
lewis okay that's it so you know that's
why i mean the thing about it is that
not only so like i said herschel gordon
lewis his movies are like goofy and
cheap and everything like that um but
i you know anybody that's into horror
movies especially like slashers or gore
films you really need to see some of his
[ __ ] because this dude was way way ahead
of his time and he didn't even really
mean to be
um he was just kind of like
uh basically he kind of started out
making like nudie films
like a lot of exploitation filmmakers
did you know back in the 50s and stuff
and that money was yeah yeah exactly and
then he had the idea like for blood
feast that you know because most of his
[ __ ] was playing like on the drive-in
circuit or exploitation cinemas stuff
like that so he's just kind of like well
what if i you know up the ante because
he's just trying to get people to go see
the [ __ ] right so he's just like well
i'm gonna make it like super
gory and bloody so he makes blood feast
and it's this massive massive success
and so from that he decides that he's
gonna make uh you know another one
because this is like really successful
with this kind of horror [ __ ] that he's
doing now this one uh
this one came out because blood feast
came out in 1963
and then this one came out the next year
and he actually i can't remember what
the budget on this was maybe sixty
thousand dollars maybe
um but it was a much bigger budget than
he had for blood feast i've seen blood
feast as well
um
and it's kind of like
it's still fun but it doesn't have a
real coherent story this one kind of
actually does interestingly the story
for this was inspired by the producer
dave friedman being in new york city and
seeing the musical brigadoon
uh you know which if you haven't seen
that we watched it in high school chorus
but it's about a village in the you know
scottish highlands that only like
appears once every hundred years
so uh so he got the idea to do that but
like in a civil war like the south is
gonna rise again context
and uh
so not only is this the second only the
second gore film ever made that they
know of this is also
i believe and please correct me if i'm
wrong the first exploitation film yeah
so every so every subsequent one from
texas chainsaw massacre hills half eyes
you know any of that [ __ ] this is where
it all started yeah this is where it all
started this is not seven this is the
first one that did this and uh and like
i said he wasn't even seeing he wasn't
trying to do anything like particularly
original they just thought like the
whole brigadoon thing would be a good
idea yeah and it was just like this
southern town that you know yeah the
whole idea is there's this
southern town that emerges out of
nowhere
on the 100-year anniversary of something
with the civil war battle where somebody
was doing it was like at the end of the
civil war was the story and there was
like a rogue group of like six yankees
and they came through this town which is
called pleasant valley it's not a real
town obviously
and uh killed all 2 000 of the
inhabitants men women and children
and so
so everybody's dead
spoiler alert it's ghosts yeah there
goes uh or revenants i guess would be a
better way of putting it so on the 100th
anniversary of that
uh you know the town everybody in the
town comes back to life and they're
having a centennial
and they need
uh six yankees the first ones that kind
of happened by down the road to yeah and
the revenants looking they're looking at
the license plates of people coming
through and they're diverting the
yankees towards this towel
and then there's a big celebration going
on they're all waving well what you what
you would call today confederate flags
those that is not the confederate flag
that's the [ __ ] battle flag of uh i
think lee's army which is you know the
the one the x on it but because people
wouldn't recognize what the real
confederate flag looked like yeah they'd
be like what the [ __ ]
is that yeah but uh it wasn't as cool as
the [ __ ] battle flag but and then uh
they're having big parades so they start
talking people into joining up enjoying
these big festivals and it's all like
fun and
trolling and the the mayor is basically
[ __ ] a cracker you know he's like a
foghorn like well come on out people you
know he's like something from another
era
belvedere come here yeah yeah yeah
those guys did exist when i was a kid
they were running around mississippi
still
um
but
it's just kind of a silly movie fun
i mostly just enjoyed it for the stupid
[ __ ] stunts that they would do to
kill people throw rocks on them and
[ __ ] cut them up some of the shit's
looking pretty gory way ahead of it's
time for 1964 i mean obviously it looks
fake and the blood is like bright red
because i don't think they even figured
out how to make more realistic stage
blood until like this late 70s or early
80s maybe uh so prior to that and like
you see this in a lot of giallo movies
and stuff like that too like the the
blood just looks like [ __ ]
tempera paint yeah it is cool though
because you know it's weird
juxtapositions of some you know some
girl [ __ ] screaming begging for her
life and people laughing while they're
cutting their fingers off you know it's
like something out of them house with a
thousand corpses those regions like i
like that i mean it's not like that
glorious right by today's standards but
considering that this was made in 1964
and this is only the second movie to
ever do this to be like a gore film
um it's actually pretty i mean obviously
when this came out uh you know the mpa
tried to cut it and everything like that
but it mostly just went around to
drive-ins and honestly like it was
really really successful on the drive-in
circuit in the south
um
which yeah you can totally see why even
though i don't even it's weird because
uh the movie is not really it's kind of
making fun of the southerners but it's
kind of making fun of the other people
too yeah the whole thing's a spoof yeah
it's kind of like satirical like the
whole kind of so nobody really comes
even the victims in this are kind of
made to look like
not all of them like there's a couple
that are that are good but
they're kind of made to look sort of
like degenerate or like you know it's
like oh this one's there like there's
married couples and they're just going
like [ __ ] around on each other and
[ __ ] like that so they're kind of made
to look immoral i guess yeah well what
you're dealing the southern characters
are being presented in kind of
stereotypical form what what the
northern stereotype of a southerner is
the northerners are being kind of
portrayed in this in the southern
stereotypes of what a northerner is yeah
degenerate
sexual deviants
[ __ ] you know what i mean
authoritarian scumbags you know people
that snotty looking down on you that
kind of [ __ ] that's what they're doing
yeah one of the things it really they
could have done better they actually
were kind of light-handed on the yankees
there was
because
[ __ ] my grandparents
or you know
they [ __ ] hated northerners hated
them that it's a kind of hatred that
doesn't really even exist anymore they
hated them all right um and
they would say things about them that
was much worse than what they showed
here
which they could have gone that route
it could have been a lot more extreme
well yeah but i mean you didn't want
them because they were actually like
just innocent victims really um and they
were just being punished as a proxy for
something they didn't have anything to
do with you know exactly it sounds
familiar that's what happens with the
south too
well that's well that's what i'm saying
but that's why they're goofing on it
yeah yeah and well yeah that's the thing
so they didn't go that far but they did
kind of you know there were a couple
scenes where like some of the
northerners like i said they were all
like screwing around in their spouses
one of them got like [ __ ] falling
down drunk and [ __ ] like that but i mean
they weren't terrible people otherwise
though and honestly like the two
northerners that kind of like get away
uh one of whom this is like really funny
because the other it's six people like i
said because they're trying to do like a
proxy for the six yankee soldiers that
killed everybody a hundred years ago so
they specifically needed six so they
just have two carloads of people so the
first one has like two married couples
who are on their way to florida and then
the second car
is was driven by uh this one woman who's
played by connie mason who was the
playboy playmate uh from for 1963. yeah
that's another thing about that she
doesn't get naked in it though so don't
get excited no i don't think there's any
nudity at all in this is there i don't
know there isn't i don't think now that
i'm thinking about it but no nudity yeah
pretty much all the girls are cute in it
though yeah they went out of their way
to make sure they're cute girls in it
which it's you know well like i said h.g
lewis came from nudie films so obviously
they're gonna do that although that's
why it surprised me that there's not any
nudity in this
probably wouldn't have gotten proper
ratings if there was nudity and violence
and violence in the same thing the same
movie because that's kind of something
like that yeah you couldn't really put
it's like well you can have one or the
other you can't have both
which is like really funny i kind of get
where they were coming from but yeah
they didn't want us they wouldn't want
to sexualize violence or make you know i
mean they didn't want to portray sex and
violence being mixed together right
right i didn't want that which yeah that
went right by the
out the window didn't it like a few
years later but you know right for a
while that was like that yeah but yeah
so i think like the most titillating
shot of her uh is she goes in the water
to like to wash mud off or something and
just like lifts up so you can see like
part of her thigh i think it's gonna
happen that's about it so don't be
disappointed it's like you don't get to
see any boobies or anything but so her i
guess she was driving wherever and she
picked up a dude uh named tom
who was a teacher and he was on his way
to a teacher's conference and his car
broken down so she picked him up like
being a good samaritan now this is
really funny too i'm not actually sure
if this is tr i've heard this
but they make a big deal
uh in the movie of these two not being a
couple because she's like she's just
some random it's just some perfect
stranger i picked up on the side of the
road but i think those two were actually
married in real life when the when the
movie was made yeah that would be lost
that would be lost on modern audiences
of why they keep saying whether they're
not married
back in those days
a a man and a woman who were not married
should not have been
even associated with one another yeah
okay so and that might have been illegal
in certain states and in certain certain
counties
yeah especially in the south
yeah and they would have 60s yeah and
they did make kind of a big show of like
putting them in separate hotel rooms and
all this other kind of right now i
wouldn't have been statewide stuff it
would have been by county
uh in the south uh
the south to this day certain in
mississippi and alabama depending on the
counties still kind of have what will
kind of be considered sharia law
you know if it's like a christian
version of it no alcohol no uh
no pornography uh you probably couldn't
associate with anybody you weren't
married to the thing is is those laws
are on the books
a lot but they're not really being
enforced i mean a lot of them are very
unenforceable especially like the sexual
ones it's like yeah how are they gonna
know like what yeah dildos you have in
your house right
if you're a regular listener i don't
know we've talked about this before what
that the deal was with that in the south
is uh church groups would take over
entire counties and pass laws that were
targeted towards people that were not in
their church with the idea of driving
them out they were using law fit law
fair like banning alcohol to drive
people out of the account because they
wanted to control the county now did
they drink alcohol you're hell right
they did
yes they would ban alcohol on one hand
but then run stills on the other hand
just because they just because they
banned something didn't mean that they
were against it they were just trying to
drive enemies out
yeah and that's the truth
and some like you said sometimes uh
particularly in the south and smaller
towns some of those laws are still in
the books but like they're just not
nowadays they just don't enforce them
but some of them absolutely still are
yeah like dry counties still exist oh
yeah you can't sell alcohol but you can
have it you can drink it yeah so some
people have to like drive to the next
and it's not just the south either
because i think there's some in like
wisconsin and [ __ ] like that as well
um but yeah so so the story of this so
there's like you know this first carload
and like you said there they have like
two of the rednecks are out there on the
main highway
and they're diverting like if you have
like a southern license plate then
you're fine they just let you go but
because they're looking out through
binoculars but if you're from up north i
couldn't tell what that what the um what
the license plate was on the first one
like because they're obviously the
colors have changed of all the license
plates so i don't recognize that but
apparently they were from some
from up north so you know uh so yeah so
they divert the two cars into the thing
and then they're saying oh we're having
this big uh you know centennial
and you guys get to stay here you guys
are the guests of honor and they're
being super super friendly and super
like up in their faces it's like we'll
give you everything for free you can
stay in a hotel for free you can have
free food free entertainment for two
days and i mean obviously it's really
funny because i guess like back in the
60s like if you were just driving
through town nothing's wrong with their
cars or nothing like that it's not like
they
you know they like yeah we gave them
flat tires or like [ __ ] their cars up so
they couldn't leave they um you know
you'd think that if this whole town full
of people were like aggressively
friendly or like you have to stay here
for two days for our celebration i'll be
like no thanks and then you just like
hit the gas and go but back in the 60s
everybody wanted to be kind of polite
you know and they're like the town's
like don't disappoint us you guys are
the are you know the guests of honor and
you have to stay and that's they're like
um okay you know free [ __ ]
so they put them up in the hotel and
obviously you know how the shit's gonna
go right i mean the first one to go is
that uh is that one woman that was
wearing that bustier yeah remember that
yeah
she was one of the cuties
yeah well like you said everybody's cute
yeah she's like
she looked like madonna actually she
looked like madonna from the 80s it did
she looked very much like because i was
like that bustier that she was wearing i
was like i remember them still selling
that in victoria's secret like up into
the 90s yeah that's almost that same
exact one no this movie's been
remastered so it looks good it's it's
actually in hd you can see it you know i
mean it doesn't have that you know
grainy or
fuzzy kind of imagery you can see things
clearly so you can see
what people look like for real you know
kind of we were marveling over stuff in
there you know like they're in this
hotel and
the telephone is obviously from the
1930s it's one of those kinds that you
do like this and there's no dial on it
and it's painted to match the wall in a
national wall
that was like very very in two of the
rooms it's really weird yeah it was
probably something like bakelite or
baked or you know baked rubber or
something you know what i mean
it's just old just seeing that old [ __ ]
that was old even in the 60s
yeah and uh yeah i don't know where they
got that that was somewhere here in
florida saint cloud that's uh honestly
that is only about 26 miles from
downtown orlando because cloud is i
don't know what it looks like nowadays i
don't know it's
i'm sure that's all gone because yeah i
mean in the movie it looks like it and
honestly everybody that's in this movie
lived in that town they got pretty much
the whole town to like be in the movie
yeah so it's like hilarious i don't know
like some of the scenes because some of
the scenes are pretty gory and it's like
so they have like all these little old
ladies and [ __ ] like that yeah and
they're all like laughing that's right
squish that you know what i mean
and i was like i wonder did they like
have an insert shot later like were the
old ladies like really watching that
stuff because you think that they would
be you know oh they were probably
flushing their pearls and that's why
they were probably
handing out handing out whiskeys
[Laughter]
because yeah i got that girl's arm off
yeah
and in that day they were probably in
brand new trailers you know those uh
1950s looking down bullet shake trailers
there were a lot of those around you
know people
they were probably living in those and
stuff it's just
just having fun i think we're just
having fun i mean as there's not as many
people get killed in this it's only like
what's the body count for yeah because
the last two of the yankees actually do
get away
uh but
there so the first woman
is she just has she goes out to the
woods she's married but she goes out
with some local stud or whatever and he
takes her out in the woods whips out a
knife and then cuts her thumb off yeah
and laughs about it like it was that
he's like
whoops look what happened
and then then they take her back to like
the mayor's office or something they all
like hold her down and then chop her arm
off yeah they said they were gonna help
her they're good yeah
yeah we'll take her to a doctor and then
they chop her arm up and then later
they're having a barbecue yeah uh where
they're barbecuing her arm yeah over the
over a spit in front of people who
aren't in on it going what is that yeah
well that's it's weird because then like
the other yankees come through and i was
like you think that if you saw a human
arm on this bit you'd be like yeah i'm
i'm gonna leave town now thanks it's
like thanks for the free hotel room but
well the yankees weren't that smart i
guess well now for to that in that one
guy's defense he was like super super
drunk so you know what i mean so the
drunk guy is the next to go he just like
falls asleep and he then he kind of
wakes up and he's like yeah i wonder
where my wife went you know the one that
got her arm cut off and then so
basically they're like oh it's now it's
time for the horse race so then they end
up i mean they quarter him she was full
around on her husband too well he was
fooling around on her on her also yeah
so like i said yeah turnabout's fair
play yeah because he ran off with the
with that girl with the hair helmet and
the weird mexican dress it wasn't it was
a spanish dress or a spanish dress yeah
there's a lot of stuff that they're
showing in here that uh kind of does
kind of point out
the
southern stuff you know the spanish and
the french were here long before there
was the united states
so
the idea that i don't know there's kind
of like a northern idea that the south
is just some kind of teutonic mixture of
germans and irish and stuff no the spent
the
the spanish and the french were here
first so there's a huge
influence of the old empires
you know so that's what they're talking
about in that movie it's
one of the one of the one of the hotties
the main one of the ones that they use
to bait a lot of people's
a spanish girl in his best dress
with a hair helmet with a hair it's all
kind of like fooshed over like ratted
right and i was like everyone's hair is
so crunchy in this yeah not everyone's
uh connie mason's is still like she has
that nice little betty draper flip going
on yeah but uh yeah most of the other
and it's funny because when the when the
northerners first pull up in the car i'm
like look it's a car full of flows yeah
flow from alice because they all have to
like put the things over their hair and
their hair was all kind of big and
crunchy and they all had those like you
know 60s sunglasses on yeah the dead
giveaway for us
being southerners is that uh the
interior shots all the walls are
stuccoed which yeah that's spanish
that's that's that's florida
and you know if it had if it looked
really french then that's going to be
somewhere towards mississippi gulf coast
louisiana around that area past
christian
new orleans
that area that's all french
so you we can tell just by the way the
the buildings look
you start going into the heartland of
alabama and mississippi things start
looking like british houses
you know yeah so you can tell
but yeah so uh so he gets quartered now
they couldn't really show that obviously
because again this is only the second
gore film ever made and he didn't have a
lot of money uh so they mostly just
imply that he gets pulled apart and then
they'll have like the horses going and
then like dragging the rope with like a
leg or something like attached to it and
it's bloody and it looks it does look
pretty good but like i said you gotta
use your imagination and then the next
guy
they they're like oh well his game is
the barrel roll so they make him crawl
into a barrel they said we're just going
to roll you down the hill it'll be fine
yeah this is my favorite one i think and
uh they're like oh and by the way we're
also going to hammer these big long
tails into it yeah and then they roll up
down the hill like [ __ ] yeah which
that's a good idea nail filled barrel
yeah then you got the [ __ ] barrel
with nails going through it they rolled
his ass down in that when they get and
he's all [ __ ] [ __ ] up and bloody
when he gets to the bottom and then the
last kill which may be the last kill is
my favorite that's like the last girl
and they tie her to this platform
um
and they have this big it's kind of like
a a dunk tank yeah you know like a
carnival but
um there's this big huge rock how did
they get that rock up there now that i'm
thinking it's a movie that rock was the
size of a vw bug yeah it was it's a
massive boulder and ended up on top of a
dumb platform and they took a little
redneck and he uh and he's like i got
one of these newfangled softballs yeah
yeah
he said something like that and he's
gonna go and he uh they were shooting it
at this little target that was yeah duct
tape and he hit it on the first try and
was hooping and hollering rock falls
down the girl crushes it crashing
they're all laughing
well yeah the funny thing about it is
that one she kind of goes along with it
i mean i guess she was outnumbered so
it's not really like she could do
anything about it but so they tie her to
the thing and then the mayor's you know
trying to get her to say she's like you
have to watch and tell us like when it's
gonna fall and so every time somebody
misses the target you have to say it
ain't fallen yet and she says it hasn't
fallen yet she's like oh excuse my
grammar yeah because she wouldn't say
ain't yeah
yeah
that like i don't know why that baby
laughed so much it just really did but
yeah so she make humor she yeah i guess
so but yeah she gets smashed
they start they start correcting the
yankees on how to speak english you know
just i don't know
people probably didn't catch it because
he said uh what was it the mayor said
something we're waiting on you and she
and she goes waiting okay yeah we're
waiting for you he goes no we're not
waiting for you we're waiting on you
it's just because yeah they don't it
just happened a couple of times but yeah
it's like the very subtle where the
right where the northerners were like
correcting their grammar right yeah but
then that but it was kind of
now the southerners were correcting the
northerners grammar yeah well no i'm
just saying yeah and then it's just like
there's a lot of [ __ ] that unless you
grew up in the south and you understand
the old south that you just you just
wouldn't get it you wait on people you
don't wait for them another thing is
that we don't have lunch here all right
it's breakfast supper and dinner
breakfast dinner dinner
lunch breakfast dinner although i kind
of feel like that's more an old school
thing that was that was like my
grandparents age yeah i used to [ __ ] up
and say lunch a lot i'd have [ __ ]
four or five of them goes ah we don't
have that here
and i was like oh yeah we don't have
that here they refused to say lunch like
i said that was a that was a
grandparents that's our grandparents
area because after that like father
sarah
yeah but you know
after that my parents and you know my
generation they did start saying lunch
because like i said even back in the old
mass media [ __ ]
programs you to say lunch well back in
the old days my grandfather used to call
he didn't call it a lunch box he called
it a dinner pail dinner poop yeah yeah
and then supper was the evening meal
yeah
which yeah which my grandparents still
called it that yeah but
and if you [ __ ] says suffer what the
[ __ ] is that they'd get pissed pull out
the bible and start [ __ ] scenes where
jesus had a supper
we're having the same thing as jesus
happened now were they serious
not really they were their resistance to
assimilation was serious but they were
just the idea was they just wanted to
put their foot down and protect their
ways
and there's a lot of that in this movie
you know that's there's the spirit
behind it
yeah even though it's just i mean it's a
very silly goofy
exploitation film i didn't even mention
that you know the very the ear worm at
the beginning like south's gonna rise
again yeah you know that that i hope you
like bluegrass if you watch this movie
because holy crap um the actually the
the band that's in it like the guys that
are playing the banjos are called the
pleasant valley boys
so yeah but honestly that that theme
song uh h.g lewis not only wrote
directed uh and did the cinematography
for this movie he also wrote and i think
sang that theme song okay so he's
you know man of many talents we have
foreigners in here don't know what
bluegrass is bluegrass music is
pretty common in the southern regions
um
it's
mutant irish
folk music what it is it comes from iron
which banjos yeah with banjos and stuff
it's kind of like the southern version
of connor you know dexy's midnight
runners you know
like that but just even more mutated
yeah
yeah but yeah that's like so yeah
there's a lot of bluegrass music but
yeah i did want to bring that up because
that song i mean they use it at the
beginning and then they use it like
throughout the movie and it will
absolutely be stuck in your head
for eternity from you know going forward
because
it's uh
it's real catchy gonna say uh so yeah
this movie as i said very very
influential had a bunch of fans like i
said rob zombie was into the [ __ ] uh lux
interior from the cramps uh also a big
fan and uh he said something about he
was laughing about the [ __ ] that
scene where they squished that girl too
and like all the old ladies that like
lived in the town going what's going on
that kind of [ __ ] uh i will say too uh
john waters was also a big fan of this
he made a movie called multiple maniacs
kind of like an homage to this uh the
band ten thousand maniacs uh used this
movie as an inspiration for their name
and uh this movie was also
it's kind of a remake and it's kind of a
sequel
and i think it came it was 2001 maniacs
and uh you know uh what's his uh [ __ ]
freddy krieger what's his name uh [ __ ]
goddammit why can't i can't robert
england robert england was in it and
that came out in when did that come out
the 90s i want to say i think it was
like 1990.
no it's 2005. okay it's like later than
i thought i've seen that as well
but i don't really remember much about
it we probably should have watched that
too because i think that's also on to be
this is actually on to be right now i
think blood feast is too and uh color me
blood red so if you want to watch his
whole uh you know hd lose his whole what
they call the blood trilogy yeah i want
to see more of it uh as i said yeah i
mean color me blood red is basically
that's about i i reviewed that a while
back but that's like about an artist
that you know uses his own blood for
paint uh and blood feast is kind of just
about a guy who's trying to
what's he trying to do he's trying to
like cut up a bunch of people and make
like a big feast for some egyptian
goddess he's trying to bring back or
some [ __ ] like that i don't know but so
so they don't really have any thematic
uh you know
nothing that ties them together
just the fact that they're all kind of
like gore movies southern horror movies
and like i said i'm pretty sure this was
the first one yeah southern hormones
kind of like
stuff that inspired rob zobby that's
good you know yeah or like i said just
even from this yeah even from the 70s
like toby hooper and stuff like that
like texas chainsaw massacre hilltop
eyes yeah all that kind of stuff this is
like the first hillbilly horror movie
right as far as i'm aware
i mean yeah even though technically
southerners are not hillbillies no i'm
just saying but that's what they call it
hillbilly horror that's the name of it
or i call it or i call it exploitation
exploitation yeah which uh you know
that's that's another phrase but yeah uh
but no that's what they call it ahead
would be hillbilly
yeah pumpkin head which is in a mythical
location that's supposedly california
there there is no place like that in
california
in in pumpkinhead
yeah well yeah that's just where they
shot it yeah and in the modern era it
looks like something from the 1920s like
where the [ __ ] is it yeah it looks like
when is this looks like some dust
[ __ ] yeah
yeah which is kind of see how pumpkin
had another good movie if you haven't
seen that yeah we did a review of that a
little while back but yeah so
as i said this movie it's just a fun i
mean the acting's bad um you know
everyone's way over the top yeah um you
know there's not that many kills in it
but the kills in it are pretty creative
and are pretty gory for 1964. but i mean
if you're really into gore films or if
you're into horror if you're into like
like i said hillbilly horror then
probably you need to see this because
this is kind of where it all started
just a fun indie movie yeah it's just
way ahead of his time like i said it's
just fun and like i said i like the
twist too
that when the last two um you know
victims get away and then they go and
report it to the cops and then they go
back and the town is gone just like
brigadoon uh so and then the funny thing
too is that like at the end before the
last of the two ghosts disappear like
the really rednecky guys uh they're
always kind of like they can't wait
until the next centennial so they're
gonna like come back again another they
said maybe we'll
he says something like maybe we'll get
to get some yankees with a rocket ship
or something like that so it's like how
do they know about rocket ships don't
think about it too much but yeah so
they're supposed to they're going to
come back every 100 years and so in 2065
somebody should make
uh another one in 2065. that's not that
far away just make another one where
they all come back and kill a bunch of
people that would be like super funny i
was thinking that when i was reading the
wikipedia page i said somebody should
remember and do it but uh yeah so this
is on 2b at the moment so you can watch
it for free uh so let us know what h.g
lewis movies you've seen because like i
said he's made a [ __ ] ton
and uh if you've seen this one what you
thought of it blah blah and we will see
you guys on the next movie retrospective
bye